[Rires]
je suis avec un pote Cindy tu peux pas
venir et il y a rien qui voudrait danser
avec toi il y a rien qui voudrait lancer
avec toi
les mecs tu veux danser avec benime
toi mon chéri viens à peine pour toi
[Musique]
viens ma chérie viens viens viens là
viens viens Bigard ah merde on a
Castaldi aussi venez tu veux faire un
slow casting
canal quand tu touches pas ma meuf euh
bon bah tant pis merci au revoir
non merci on a Delphine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a qu'une autre la ramenez-vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai envie de manger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mets-toi là mets-toi là non non natation
[Rires]
[Musique]
attention tout le monde
allez check
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]